there are new court documents that are
out right now dated may 26th
and june 1st relating to george floyd
george floyd the the man who died
uh in police custody in minneapolis he
wasn't in
i mean he was on the ground the police
were arresting him he had been resisting
arrest
then he was on the ground and and very
sadly he died
and this sparked all of these riots you
know that we've been dealing with for
the past several months
so the question is was george floyd
asphyxiated was he choked to death
you know they always talked about the
police officer's knee on his neck
and george floyd said i can't breathe i
can't breathe now meanwhile let's not
forget george floyd also was yelling i
can't breathe even before the officers
really touched him when he was resisting
arrest earlier in and around his own car
so
that this it was it was difficult to
believe it at the moment because he had
already been saying it for a long time
but the chief hennepin county medical
examiner dr andrew baker
now according to these new documents
concluded that george floyd likely died
from a fentanyl overdose and found quote
no physical evidence suggesting that he
died of asphyxiation
they said that if mr floyd had been
found dead in his home or anywhere else
and there were no other contributing
factors he would conclude that it was an
overdose death
we'd been hearing about this for a while
george floyd despite the mainstream
media's
whitewashing to the contrary had been
there not only resisting arrest
uh but was also on a insanely high
dosage
of illegal drugs very powerful drugs
that people die from every single day in
this country
now because he was obviously
under this intense stress you could see
his behavior was so erratic even from
the moment that the cops came and
knocked on his window
it was so intense and erratic that that
may have contributed some to his death
the fact that he was on the ground and
the cop had his knee on his neck
that may have contributed to some of the
stress that then caused his death
you can't take out of that the fact that
he was on
apparently possibly a lethal dose of
fentanyl already
doesn't matter the left doesn't want to
hear that they're going to erase it
they're going to force
the medical examiner to change his
conclusions which is
which is what has happened here the
medical examiner did now conclude
otherwise
the left is out for blood despite
the sign of the scientists right this
guy the medical examiner is obviously a
scientist
the left is out for blood and they're
attacking anybody that they can to vent
their rage i hope you enjoyed that short
segment from the michael knowles show be
sure to check out the full episode
linked in the description
or download the podcast wherever you
listen to podcasts
[Music]
[Music]
you